[Music]
i'll call the meeting to order
um welcome all
uh
i'll call for apologies do we have any
apologies
we appear to have none
uh
yes
thank you
thank you uh
council redmond is your name isn't it
that's right
seconded council mailings
all those in favor
against carried thank you conflicts any
conflicts of interest to be recorded
appear to have none uh confirmation of
the minutes just before we ask for a
mover of that can we have it recorded
that uh councilor millions was an
apology
we had an email
to that effect um
just been missed off the minutes so with
that correction do we have mover council
black is moving seconded by councillor
redman
oh i know where i'm getting mixed up
that moved
the mirror seconded councillor redmond
uh
all those in favor
against carrick
matters are rising
appear to be none deputations we don't
have any so we'll move straight into
reports and call on mr bacon
uh for item 6.1
pages 11 to 15.
excellent thank you uh so i'll give my
apologies on behalf of tracy who's not
here today and so i'm sort of up here
filling in for her and i'll do this
report as well so look i didn't have uh
too much to add to this report uh
probably just an update
uh resource consent numbers uh
to
february have been still quite quiet so
we're not getting a lot of uh consent
applications in but we are still
certainly still busy with dealing with
the um
the end processes of the consents that
we had through last year as well so
it's probably a key thing to highlight
and happy to answer any questions
any questions
appear to be none and do we have a mover
moved council of duty seconded
councillor whitman councillor duty
thank you very much it's just
interesting just um that uh everything's
sort of quiet and down about which is a
good job because you gives you time to
get the rest of the catch up on me
so have you got just a question for you
have you got any um sticky ones are they
really going to be quite simple simple
ones to deal with
and no most of the consents that have
come in um
simple is probably the wrong word but um
yeah yeah able to be dealt with there's
nothing nothing big that's come in
recently
council reading
just to say that the
the unit's been very busy with the large
increase in consents and i think you're
doing very well to be keeping up with
most of them
so uh well done to the staff and the
team
any further speakers
peterbino i'll put that all those in
favor
item 7.1
the request for the loading zone
on railway road pages 16-20
and again is that change not here i
assume that's for you
i suppose it can be uh myself so i've
read the report i think um
seems to be fairly self-explanatory um
approving a uh loading zone um in
railway road
uh i'm happy to take any questions that
i can try and answer
thank you matt if not we will we will
get shane to come down if we need him
wendy yeah
matt i'm just wondering um with this
where does this sort of fit between you
between roading and
and um
dpnr how does that how does it sort of
fall into your category
sure so i suppose uh the requests has
come through the roading team
uh and so they've looked at it from a
sort of a technical standpoint in terms
of um the detail of the road how large
the stopping bay needs to be etc etc uh
and it intersects with the
planning and regulation uh department
sort of due to um the enforcement of
that so if if we even needed to go down
and do any enforcement say someone was
parking in there that's where
the regulation team would get involved
as well
does that apply all over all over the
waimaka area wherever there's a loading
bank
does that apply the same scenario thank
you any further questions
moved uh
mia gordon seconded
council meetings
uh
council gordon just briefly mia gordon
if you like
oh that's fine
thank you thank you deputy miriam
miss cheerson
be quiet over there his raw highness
[Laughter]
i i this has been through the ranger
ashley community board and they've
obviously supported this it's a request
because it makes sense to me uh peck and
save is a really important business in
our district uh
and what they're asking for for a
loading zone there makes um makes
perfect logical sense uh and it helps
with the operation effective operation
of their business so
um i've no hesitation in supporting it
thank you
councilman
any further speakers
appear to be none i'll put that all
those in favor
against
carried thank you
uh i have no correspondence portfolio
updates uh
council barnett is not here council
redmond
right thank you mr chair
it's
pretty much business as usual in
um and civil defence areas
at one of our meetings we referred to
the um civil defense emergency
management trifecta review
um
feedback has been passed on and i think
mr mayor myself
and staff
composed a submission
on that
there have been two minor
depending how you define minor flooding
events over recent
weeks
which have involved unr and
the emergency response team
the
unit continues to be very busy across
all compliance services
and there have been anecdotally some
customers becoming agitated
so there could be a heightened sense of
anxiety in the community at the moment
presumably um
prompted by coven
uh the civil defence unit
and
i think
nzrt-12
attended a number of properties during
the recent flooding events
a number of garages and outbuildings
were wet but no houses
had flood water inside them
um they evacuated one lady with a
miniature pony and 14 dogs were
evacuated from inside her house
um so they've been quite busy so they
there has been a response from civil
defence and there is a whole list of
properties that were inspected so
whilst it's business as usual for
regulation certainly the civil defence
area has been quite busy
that's uh thank you very much
uh councillor redmond
i have no questions understanding orders
uh no edu general business our next
meeting is uh 26th of april 1 pm
and i will thank you all for coming and
declare the meeting closed at uh what
are we
108.
now
we have
a couple of briefings so uh
hiker and cameron
eight minutes
[Laughter]
yes well i suppose two seconds does make
a difference when you've got eight
minutes
you